we're gonna begin with this there's a
major new development in the
investigation into the deaths of three
people in Canada including an American
woman and her Australian boyfriend
police say 19 year-old cam McCloud and
18-year old briar Chmerkovskiy are
suspects they were originally reported
as missing people police say they may be
armed Janet shamlian is in Surrey
British Columbia near where the suspects
are from Janet what do we know about
these teens well Tony this case has
taken a dramatic turn and police are now
saying that they are casting a wide net
they believe the teens are on the run
that they may have changed their
appearance and police have evidence to
suggest they may already be thousands of
miles away
if you spot Breyer or cam consider them
dangerous an intense manhunt is underway
for two Canadian teens cam McCloud and
Briar Gill ski now suspects in three
deaths on rural roads in British
Columbia Canada the search comes more
than a week after the bodies of North
Carolina native China deist and
Australia and Lukas Fowler were found
near their van on the side of the road
the young couple seen here hugging at a
gas station two days before being found
or on a road trip there was a van broke
down we just pulled over to see if they
needed to help Curtis Brown and his wife
Sandra say they met the pair shortly
before they died leaving the young
travelers only after they felt the
couple knew how to repair their
broken-down van they were happy and
smiling and they were your honor road
trip they just looked like a young
couple in love the mystery deep in late
last week when another body was found
some 300 miles away also on a remote
Canadian Road that man has not been
identified but police released this
sketch of him police say they'd found a
truck on fire that belonged to the
Canadian teen suspects about a mile from
the man's body we believe that they're
likely continuing to travel these are
newly-released recent photos of the teen
suspects last seen driving a 2011 silver
Toyota rav4 police believe they've left
British Columbia and may be in Manitoba
thousands of miles away investigators
won't say what evidence connects the
teens to their killings
for Lucas Fowler's father the loss is
unimaginable as a police officer you you
work with families all the time but
nothing prepares me nothing prepares my
family for what we are going through now
a father's heartbreak and so the
families of these teens that they
haven't seen them for several days and
they believe the teenagers were out on
the road looking for work meanwhile the
families of this young couple the
American and that Australian and the
father you saw just there are asking
this question about motive what could
have sparked what seems to be a random
murder gale boy Janet that is a question
everybody wants to know you know when I
was in Charlotte North Carolina earlier
this week that young woman is from
Charlotte North Carolina so that's a big
big story there they've had several
interviews at WBTV with the relatives
and they wanted another question why why
why would somebody do this to what
appeared to be a really lovely young
couple Janet we thank you again